اما بعد
الرياض الصالحين
الحافظ النووي
عمر رضي الله عنه
جبريل
عليه السلام
قال فاخبرني عن الاحسان
قال اي النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ان تعبد
يعني الاحسان
عبادتك
عبادتك الله كانك تراه فان لم تكن تراه
فانه يراك
لاحظوا هذا المعنى ان هنا المخففه ف
هي مصدريه
ايش يعني مصدريه؟ يعني هي والفعل اللي
بعدها
يجتمعان في معنى المصدر
وهذا يسمى عند العلماء بالمصدر المؤول
يكون تقدير الكلام
ان تعبد الله كانك تراه اي عباده
ك الله كانك تراه ما هو الاحسان؟ الاحسان
عبادتك الله كانك تراه فان لم تكن تراه
فانه يراك
او ان هنا مخففه بمعنى ضمير الشان انه
تعبد الله كانك تراه
وهذا ياتي في اللغه كثيرا مثل
شهاده اللا اله الا الله كثير من الناس
يغلط يقول انه لا اله الا الله خطا
لان
ان اذا كان مقدر اسم ان فانه
يخفف
so was الاحسان
الاحسان
‏per
something do here asked him what is per
with respect to
isic
he said you worship الله as if you can
see him
if you are unable to see
‏arees
gov
inan
we have those are out inwards
‏and
passing person
to
now form to perfect howes a person
islam and
it is worship
الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم wasلام
اسلام
ايمان
احسان
الاحسان
লিম
[Silence]
الله
ايمان احسان
Islam
اسلام هو الاستسلام لله بالتوحيد
والانقياد له بالطاعه والبراءه من الشرك
واهله اسلام
الله
توحيد
شرك
ايمان
ايمان هو قول باللسان
و اعتقاد بالجنان وعمل بالجواز
والاركان يزيد بطاعه الرحمن وينقص
بالعصيان
ايمان ايمان
‏actance
is that
it is belief in the heart and statement
that is in line with that belief upon
the tong and actions upon the limbs it
rises with the person obedience of Allah
and it decreases with person's
disobedience of that is what احسان احسان
هو الاتقان
احسان
[Silence]
ان تعبد الله كانك تراه
فان لم تكن تراه فانه يراك
يقول
قال فاخبرني عن الساعه
each other
secluded
صلى الله عليه وسلم
more
environ
other people exhibit lainess other
people exhibitousness
other people and we see this constantly
and this is a larger from our society
what
[Silence]
‏Qu and
are
we going beud by
who we areesterday and we are
tomorrow
اس
صلى الله عليه وسلم
التولي يوم الزحف
why
islam
‏Muslim
people
you run what happun
turn and run as well until this could
army
porun
‏unas
more
things
and
because things willable
الله سبحانه وتعالى انا نحن نكتب ما قدموا
وايش واثارهم ايش يعني اثارهم
واثار هذه الاعمال
اثر هذا العمل ايش كان اثره
على على غيره ايش كان اثره على الناس ايش
كان اثره هذا يكتب هذا من عملك
ولذلك اجمع العلماء
على ان الولد من عمل من جمله عمل الوالد
انه هذا اثر اثر لعمله
الله سبحانه وتعالى says that he
‏us
and
those
of those
so when we do something not just the act
it's not just the act itself and this is
something that war a lot more attention
that we not just look at raw data or
numbers or look at our acts
‏matematical equ
could more
because of something because we do any a
person say somethingesra
from something
they this
‏What is going to be on
triggered by this act? نسال الله سبحانه
وتعالى
ان يعلمنا ما ينفعنا وان ينفعنا بما علمنا
والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد